how do we know this is safe define say
your brainwaves and the necessary data
to pinpoint what every corner of the
universe berry is stuck but I'm not sure
about damn it you can't get him out I
can see so let me go back right now my
whole world is in danger you're not
going back
hey youtubers is Charlie we finally got
a trailer for next week's Kevin Smith
episode it's called the runaway dinosaur
so let's break it down there are two big
storylines you have this stuff that's
going on in STAR Labs are actually three
storylines because there's two different
things going on in STAR Labs you have
them trying to figure out what's going
on with Barry where he went how to bring
him back and then you have zombie girder
if you remember he was a season 1
character from the episode where Barry
learned how to do the supersonic punch
and the third story line is where Barry
is which I think is going to be a
version of the Speed Force the way it's
coming across in the trailer is him
being stuck in this otherworldly place
with beings that exist outside of
space-time because they're speaking to
him through people that he knows in
places that he knows like you have him
talking to the iris character you have
him talking to Joe you need to let me
leave I need to go home and they're
saying oh you're never leaving so it
sounds like all this is just this
environment created from his memories so
I'm assuming that he is now pure energy
and he is stuck inside the Speed Force
and this is gonna be how they depicted
there been a couple times in the comics
when speedsters have either turned into
pure Speed Force like disappeared into
the Speed Force where they turned into
lightning or some other form of energy
like a long time ago Barry turned into
the bolt of lightning that gave him
powers originally like his life became
this electrical circuit that he traveled
way back when Jay Garrick was fighting
against his version of the reverse flash
which was called edward clariss he was
also called the rival the rival
disappeared into the Speed Force but he
came back like he rima t realized as
pure energy and inhabited the body of
max mercury so you had like an evil max
mercury running around with Speed Force
powers but it was really edward clariss
inhabiting his body I don't think the
flash is gonna get that weird but the
actual trailer itself for the episode
just gets so weird and that is what I
love about the flash is that it gets way
weirder than a lot of the other DC shows
if you ever watched Hannibal that's the
show that got really weird and
psychological the flash is definitely
not that weird but it's definitely
pushing in that direction just the idea
that Barry has turned into pure energy
it is now talking to ethereal beings
that I'm assuming they'll explain in the
episode because in the comics previously
when characters get stuck in the Speed
Force there's there's not like other
people that they're talking to in there
unless Barry Allen is fighting the
reverse flash like that's the only other
time
you see characters talking to other
characters inside the speedforce
so what might be happening in this
episode is Barry is really just talking
to himself like maybe he's manifested
this from his mind and when Joe is
talking to him saying oh we're never
gonna let you leave it's like Barry's
telling himself that like he won't let
himself move forward so he has to jump
over like this big mental hurdle like
imagine the psychological journey of the
flash this season you know recognizing
his own self-worth making peace with his
demons coming to the conclusion that he
is an awesome person so that he can beat
the out of zoom so that might be
what's happening in this episode where
he justly comes to the conclusion
they're like oh I can totally do this
I'm a total badass and then just kind of
reforms out of the Speed Force but the
other really awesome weird thing about
it is the title the runaway dinosaur
what does that title mean look way down
here in the corner the runaway dinosaur
is the title of this children's book so
it looks like in his mind like in the
Speed Force he's manifested this
construct of the night that his mother
was murdered so he goes back to the
beginning I love the way the flash
travels in a circuit just like he does
in the comics it always revolves around
specific moments so no matter how far he
travels he always comes back to the
point of origin but I do think they'll
have some fun with the idea of runaway
dinosaurs in jokes that they make like
verbal references well let me know what
do you think happened to Barry do you
think he's inside the Speed Force do you
think he's somewhere else he's
definitely not on another planet I do
like the theory these jump to another
dimension but like I said I still think
that he's inside the Speed Force we'll
just have to wait and see how the show
explains that because they're just a
number of different directions they
could take it because remember they're
changing a few things from the comics so
the Speed Force on the TV show isn't
exactly like the Speed Force in the
comics but it's pretty close what about
the costume though it totally got
shredded a lot of you've been asking is
he gonna get a new suit now they do
change the suit just a little bit every
year even within each year they make
additions like Cisco adds tech here and
there it could be that they're
redesigning like a completely different
suit that'll look way more badass so the
odds are 50/50 on a completely new suit
redesigned especially going into season
3 but for those you're asking next big
video is gonna be Captain America Easter
eggs hopefully you guys have had a
chance to see the movie if you haven't
tell them to shut up
take my money why you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for my non-spoilery Captain America
Civil War review and you can click here
to start getting ready for Game of
Thrones this weekend thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight